-Il vous pose des questions ?
-Oui, oui.
-Beaucoup ?
-Pas mal.
-Et vous répondez à toutes ?
-Non.
Quelques-unes.
-Comment vous faites
pour l’exaspérer ?
-Pour l'exaspérer,
c'est facile.
C'est drôle,
parce qu'il est très généreux,
le gâchis ça l'énerve,
par exemple,
frotter les allumettes,
et j'aime bien l'odeur après.
Ou écrire sur des bouts de papier,
ça l'énerve beaucoup.
Mais ça dépend...
Et de perdre aussi.
Je suis assez désordonnée.
Ca, ça l'énerve.
-Elle est merveilleuse avec moi,
mais j'ignore ce qui a dans sa tête.
J'ignore exactement
quelle est son attitude.
Elle est si délicieuse
que je me demande si elle
n'est pas comme ça avec moi
un petit peu par compassion,
en se disant : "Peut-être
qu'il a besoin de moi."
J'ai peur des fois que ce soit ça,
parce qu'elle est tellement
délicieuse et adorable.
Et je ne voudrais pas qu'on fasse
quelque chose pour me faire plaisir.
Je voudrais que tout
ce qu'elle fait avec moi,
ce soit pour faire plaisir à elle.
-Il se met rarement en colère.
Contre moi, il s'y est mis 2 fois.
Et une fois, c'était en jouant.
On jouait aux cartes, je crois.
Et moi, je suis très mauvaise
joueuse, je déteste de perdre.
Et il faisait exprès
de me faire perdre, mais vraiment.
Il faisait exprès de me faire
perdre pour me faire pleurer.
Un jour, je suis partie
de la table,
il a couru vers moi, il m'a dit :
"Petite conne, remets-toi à table !"
Et je suis allée, parce que
je ne l'avais jamais vu comme ça.
Ca, ça m'a marquée.